So it's a little bit easier to
understand what these eigenvectors do,
if we look at it this way.
Here are the principle component
eigenvectors, one through whatever.
Here's two different reconstructions,
all right.
If I take the average face, and
I just add three times, and sigma
k is just the standard deviation of
the coefficient, don't worry about that.
If I take the average face and
I add in some of that component,
I get this kind of thing.
And if I subtract off that kind of
component, I get that thing.
Notice, that that just moved
the lighting from the left to the right.
So one way of thinking about
it is that these components,
the first components just
change with the direction,
lighting direction was from
the left to the right.
Whereas, let's see,
let's take another one.
Here, this component here,
if I add positive, I don't know,
it tends to look a lot more feminine.
When I go negative,
it tends to look a lot more masculine.
Okay.
So each of these, different eigenvectors
are adding in some other different
variation, some other different element.
So, how do you use these?
Well, a couple of things
we have to talk about.
First is, I have to be able
to get the coefficients.
Well, that's real easy,
just like I said before.
I take in some image, x, here it is, and
I just subtract off the mean,
the mean face.
And I take the dot product with,
in this case, the first eigenvector,
second, third,
all the way up to the kth eigenvector.
Those dot products will give
me these coefficients, or
weights, w1 through w k.
What's cool is that vector of numbers,
just k of them, maybe it's 20,
maybe it's 200, that's my entire
representation of this face.
So I've taken this 10,000-dimensional
vector, 10,000 elements,
10,000 pixels, and
I've reduced it to 20 numbers.
So how do we make use of this vector,
these w's that are the coefficients?
Well, the first thing is, I can actually
use them to reconstruct the face.
Right?
Each one of these w's tells me how much
of each eigenvector to add back in.
And in general,
what I can do is I take a picture and
I say this picture is represented
by the mean plus the w's,
each of the w's times the eigenvector,
because that's what this is.
And if I were to keep a lot of them, I
would get a really great reconstruction.
If I keep some of them,
I get an okay reconstruction.
Well, how many of them
do I want to keep?
Well remember, I wasn't doing
this to do a reconstruction,
I was trying to do recognition.